esta segunda jornada de la fase de
grupos nos ha dejado dos nuevas
elecciones clasificadas a octavos de
final aquí en Qatar 2022 Por una parte
Brasil por el grupo G mientras que
Portugal logra pasar a la siguiente
ronda por el grupo H Brasil venció por
la mínima diferencia a la selección de
Suiza gracias a un gol de casemiro
mientras que Portugal ganó por un
doblete de Bruno Fernández ante nada más
y nada menos que Uruguay En todo caso
antes en más temprano el día de hoy
Camerún se enfrentó a hacer bien uno de
los dos partidos más espectaculares del
día de hoy partido que terminó en empate
13 por 3 pero las dos selecciones pues
se ponen en aprietos con este resultado
la próxima fecha Camerún se enfrentará a
Brasil mientras que Serbia lo hará ante
suiza en cuanto al grupo H pues la
selesaba como ya les venía diciendo
logró esta Victoria ante los charrúas
que salió muy prudente a ese terreno de
juego y tendrán que enfrentarse a gana
las estrellas a negras que ganaron otro
de los partidos más lo del día de hoy
una victoria de tres goles por dos ante
Corea del Sur La que sí los va a tener
bastante difícil será precisamente esta
selección asiática que tendrá Sí o sí
que salirle a ganar a Portugal los
partidos de estos grupos se disputarán
el próximo viernes